all right grasshoppers invade the valley
do you all remember this fiasco now this
took apart this happened back in the
summer of night of 2019 well sally
haramido takes us back in time after
speaking to an expert who tells us if
this unique experience could happen
again
[Music]
it was so crazy i think the biggest
thing was just
the sheer mass of how many grasshoppers
there were miles reynolds lives in the
northwest valley he remembers this event
vividly he likes to call it something
out of the norm just like when we see
snow in las vegas it was just like a
wall of grasshoppers and the light
i had never seen anything like it jeff
knight is a state entomologist with the
nevada department of agriculture he says
while this is unusual it's happened more
than once the populations got real high
they started migrating
they came through las vegas
and this is an event that has occurred
in the past the insects are driven by
unusual wet weather that was what
happened the winter of 2018 here and in
arizona once grasshoppers became adults
with wings they started heading north
when they get to las vegas they're
attracted to the lights
so they start moving into the strip and
some businesses didn't think twice
before they joined the grasshopper trend
with exotic drinks and food options we
wanted to
welcome the grasshoppers we're gonna
drink something in your honor
and our our sister
restaurant evil pie did a grasshopper
pizza when asked if it can happen again
i think you can say eventually it will
happen again we're ready we're going to
grasshopper 2.0 is even going to be even
better you think the end of the world is
going to be zombies but i was like is it
going to be grasshoppers sally caramillo
live local now